x-men The Last Stand was directed by
Brett Ratner not Bryan Singer Bryan
Singer backed out of this film to do
Superman Returns which I think we all
can agree was a colossal mistake
in fact Bryan Singer has even said that
publicly that he wished he had done that
and even tried to redo things that this
film did with Days of Future past to
help fix the continuity errors that this
film brought upon the entire x-men
series now do I hate x-men the last
stand no I actually really enjoyed the
first half of the last stand we'll talk
about some of the pros and some of the
cons when Brett Ratner took this project
he had very little time and the fact of
this film is as good as it is and not
quite as terrible as it could have been
is actually rather commendable the movie
opens with a Danger Room sequence it was
really cool to finally see the danger
room in use at Xavier school but this
scene is a good indication of my biggest
issue with the entire film and this is a
very action heavy scene and it's very
fun and it's exciting but there is
nothing at stake it doesn't feel like
there's any urgency the first two x-men
films felt almost like dramas that
contained amazing action sequences you
felt for the characters you understood
the world it was about persecution and
discrimination about being different and
how to be accepted in humanity when you
are different x-men The Last Stand sort
of throws all that away and it's an
action movie the action sequences are
very well held there's a lot of really
impressive special effects and it's
overall a fun exciting summer popcorn
movie that you can watch and be
entertained by but it took the dramatic
Heights that were reached in the first
two films and kind of threw them out the
door for a bunch of impressive set
pieces and that was disappointing there
are still some things you can glean from
this movie though in regards to a
dramatic kept there are some good
character moments like in the beginning
when Logan is getting scolded by storm
for not doing a very good job of being a
teacher in the Danger Room and kind of
taking things on his own he says hey I'm
just a sub talked to Scott he didn't
show up and you're like Wolverine is a
substitute teacher that's that's just
interesting to me could you imagine
being in school and like you
teachers gone for the day and in walks
Wolverine I mean that would be the best
day of school ever there's also a great
moment between Scott and Logan when
they're both talking about how they have
to move on from G and GRA dying and
Scott goes hey not everybody heals as
fast as you Logan and walks away that's
a great line whenever you can take our
characters larger-than-life superhero
ease stuff and bring it down to earth
and have it relate to their human
emotion or in this case mutant emotion
it makes the characters more relatable
not just people in spandex and superhero
suits also storm has given a lot more to
do in this film which was nice to see
kelsey grammer as the beast is an
inspired choice that is a fantastic
casting decision I love him as his
character I would have never ever
thought that and the fact that they went
for that and it worked as well as it did
that's commendable and that's one of the
things about the x-men franchise as a
whole that I love is the casting choices
because when you look back on these
films it's tough to imagine any other
actor inhabiting these characters and
this films does set up a very
interesting and complex dilemma humans
have discovered a cure for the mutant
gene do you take it or do you not now
for some it's appalling but for others
like rogue who can't touch them on
without essentially killing them that's
a kind of attractive prospect so are you
for or against the Cure that aspect of
this movie I think is very compelling
there's also a great scene that comes
from Logan and rogue having a
conversation where Roe was going off to
get the Cure and Logan's like hey I'm
not your father
I'm your friend do what you got to do if
you want to do it do it just do it for
yourself not for some boy there's a lot
of character moments like that in the
first half of the Last Stand
but I really like it it's one of the
reasons I do own the blu-ray I love
magneto just turning his back on
mystique when she gets the cure by
accident he's just like oh you're not
one of us anymore and walks away but
what this film explores the most is what
was only hinted at in the first two
x-men's and that is Jean Grey becoming
the Phoenix and we get to see the rise
of the Dark Phoenix when she is
essentially the worst kind of bipolar
you could be because when you're on your
really bad side you can possibly destroy
the entire earth there's some really
great sequences here and I like fomka
Jensen quite a bit in this
well I think she's a fairly underrated
actress and I really like what she
brings to this character and there's an
amazing scene where Professor X gives up
his life and magneto has to sit there
and watch and there's moments where
magneto sits back in this movie and
realizes what he's done and it's kind of
heartbreaking for his character but
here's what I have to say I can't
attribute too much of that emotion to
the last stand this film I have to
attribute it to the fact that the first
two films that preceded it were so good
my best way of describing this is
imagine you love a TV show it's like one
of your favorite shows you're all built
up in the characters you really like
everybody you're excited you can't wait
to watch it every week or maybe you
binge it on Netflix you get to season
five and you're loving it you're loving
every minute and there's one episode
that comes along that's kind of crappy
it's not the greatest episode but you
can kind of watch it and you feel semi
invested in this episode and in the
characters because of all of the other
good content that's come before it and
that's kind of how I feel about The Last
Stand the first two films are so good
and they got me so into these characters
that this film is really benefited from
that this film has the first two films
to thank for the fact that I care even
remotely because this film doesn't do
much to set up these characters in an
entertaining way beyond some action
set-pieces I like the first two so much
and so I kind of carry over that emotion
and character development into this film
a little bit so let's get into some of
the negatives beyond what I've already
talked about the fact that this is just
a big action movie and sort of throws
out a lot of the personal drama I think
the rogue and Kitty pride jealousy over
Iceman is completely unnecessary it's an
entire backstory to this film that I
don't think has to be there
I do like Iceman finally standing up to
pyro that sequence is awesome but I
think that entire love triangle was just
completely unnecessary and really took
us nowhere in this film let's talk about
the juggernaut so uh I don't know I I
don't like him I don't like him in this
movie I'm the juggernaut bench it's like
thanks man will you shut the fuck up and
get off this screen as the movie
transitions into an
all out action film and we finally get
the big war that we've all been hearing
about for the first two films magneto
essentially turns into a pun machine
jobs always wanted to build bridges in
chess the form scuffed up he turned from
a fairly complex character into this
action movie guy who says witty things
and winks at the camera it was a total
betrayal of everything that we've seen
of magneto in the first two films
although there is a fantastic line
delivered by Wolverine in this sequence
grow those back it's like I said there
are tiny morsels of goodness throughout
this movie that you can latch onto like
Wolverine having to kill a gene it's
very sad you feel for him he's the only
guy who can walk up to her and for
whatever reason though she chooses not
to use her telekinesis to make him fly
back I mean she does that to him earlier
in the movie I get that he's resisting
her body disintegrating powers at this
time but she could just use telekinesis
to push him back like she did earlier
but I guess she doesn't want to there's
part of her that sort of seems like she
wants to be killed in fact she asks him
twice in this movie for him to kill her
and so I can kind of forgive that but
it's also a bit of a nitpick the first
task is okay it was actually semi
watchable and I enjoyed it the last half
turns into a big action movie
extravaganza where it forgets what the
series is really about and then the end
credits scenes are like hey remember how
we had all these really dramatic moments
yes look it yeah Magneto's got to get
his powers back in and Charles Xavier is
in some body somewhere and it's his
voice and apparently it's like his twin
brother the series after this has
essentially completely ignored whatever
the fuck happened at the end of this
movie with Xavier he shows up in the end
credits sequence of The Wolverine and is
like you're not the only one with kissed
and I'm like what the hell's going on if
you're going to kill him kill him don't
have them be some twin brother that he
can inhabit that's just that is the
biggest bullshit thing they could have
done with these characters they had a
sad death and end credits scene is like
hey nope
sorry that's not how it is actually he's
he's in a twin brothers body or some
shit and the only way I know that is
because I've looked into it online the
films have completely disregarded this
incredible continuity error in fact the
x-men series as a whole has some serious
continuity issues and one of them is a
time travel movie so yeah The Last Stand
as I said I do not hate I like the first
half the last task to me really betrayed
everything the first half did as well as
the first two films I'm to give x-men
The Last Stand a C+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to my review of x-men origins Wolverine
with my buddy to flick pick you join me
filming that and I can't wait to do that
leading up to Logan you guys are the
best thank you once again and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]